bro listen listen
there's a socialist magazine just fired
all its staff because they're trying to
form a union
yeah god i love it with the young turks
the story came out last year jank yuger
was trying to union bust or whatever was
yelling at people you've got that that
bernie sanders supporting woman actually
she's rep on you nico lo she bought a
million dollar condo oh yeah yeah i'm
not i'm not gonna i'm not gonna drag the
success of these individuals who are
progressive but at the same time i'll
tell you this i'd be willing to bet
those people would not pay taxes if they
were given the choice yeah and they
would say something like what this is
this is the system we're in and i'm just
you know living the way it's supposed to
be the fact that they can find a
rationalization in their mind to be
whatever i saw one of them where he's
like where in his like you know like eat
the rich shirt or something like that
and then they show his house oh that was
a song today yeah like uh you know i
mean it's just like come on the idea
that you can justify that hypocrisy
again like you i don't hate any of their
success i actually admire it um i don't
agree with their politics but i admire
people who succeed in life and
we should all be inspired by that and
learn from that hassan streams like 10
hours a day
yeah and and so he's i i looked at his
numbers and i'm like i think he's
probably making three four million i
could be wrong just an estimate and i
got mad respect for that hustle yeah
sure and i also don't mind someone being
a progressive and believing in higher
taxes and a welfare state and all that
stuff and being rich so but the funny
thing about the hassan situation for
those that are familiar he's like the
biggest political streamer on the left
probably he bought a three million
dollar house he's getting roasted by
socialists
conservative so breitbart wrote an
article and they were like
you know socialist streamer buys three
million dollar house and i'm like i mean
it's a great story i guess i don't see
the criticism i don't know why i'd care
he's not like advocating for people not
have houses or not be rich he's just
very much for heavy taxation and i'm
sure he's paying 50 to 60 taxes but the
socialists are pissed off are they
threatening to eat him um they they
there's a they're getting their their
bibs on and their forks and they're like
no no they're defending him saying that
like there's a big difference between
jeff bezos and hassan and all that stuff
and
i that's i get it i'm not going to straw
man their argument like there's a big
difference between jeff bezos sure and a
guy on twitch yeah i mean okay fine but
you know
if you really have some perspective on
on the issue to be someone who you know
if you're worth 10 million dollars let's
just say for the sake of argument for
this guy which he's probably at least
got a net worth of that much right let's
say his net worth is 10 million if you
have a net worth of 10 million dollars
in 2021 in a first world country
compared to all of the human beings who
have ever existed throughout history
you are a level of rich that is
could would be
magic
to
99.99 of human beings who have ever
existed just couldn't even conceive
kings would have no like no concept of
the wealth that you have so to say oh
well i can compare him to jeff bezos and
he's not as rich as that guy i mean like
have some perspective you're talking
about the rich you are amongst the most
wealthy privileged human beings who have
ever existed in this like meaty flesh
balls circling around the sun that we
live on we went to a mall like two weeks
ago
and they have in when you walk in the
center is this like you know 200 foot
tall dome with you know this beautiful
glass and architecture and i looked at
it and i was like
if a king from like the medieval world
saw this he would say for what god was
this built and we'd be like i'm just
getting a mochaccino dude i don't i
don't know about no gods dude if you
could be a king in like the 1400s
or be you in this house right now i bet
you would choose being you i got a
toilet dude you got you got a toilet if
you get a headache you got some advil
somewhere i bet if you want to go
downstairs watch something you go
downstairs you turn on the big screen tv
if you were king you have to go
downstairs and have some dude like tell
stories for you and they're just the
stories might suck and you've got to
kill that dude and find a new dude to
tell you
if you want to eat ice cream they'd have
to bring the the the ice block covered
in sawdust
and then walk it up and grab the salt
and put it in the bowl with the cream
and then like use the salt ice and
you're sitting there being like i'm
going to have ice cream soon and then
it's just like bland sweet like not
sweet
we've got it's brutal we got ice cream
downstairs it's made from fungus that
they took this they genetically modified
a fungus to make whey protein and it
legit just tastes like regular ice cream
but it's made from fungus
kings would not fathom a creation of
such that's right and it's so [ __ ]
back then too they don't talk about it a
lot because they were all it was
desensitized to the stink but like if
you go to viet the vietnam soldiers came
back from being on there like the thing
you notice the most is how bad it stinks
in vietnam it's hot like hot and it
stinks the point that you're touching on
though is that and i agree is that
fundamentally there is a difference
between like a self-made millionaire
that worked you know pulled themselves
up from their boobs strats and and the
corporatists the problem is and i know
this doesn't apply to like jimmy dore
and like the the better half of the
progressives but the left has become
corporatist and that has been made very
clear with these bailouts or not i'm
sorry not the bailouts the lockdowns
because
you know who made out on that and who's
who's morally in support of the
lockdowns the left
this is my thing with like the hassan
buying the big house i'm like i'm i'm
glad he got a big house i think that's
fantastic and you know the socialists
who are criticizing or criticizing him
for the wrong reasons criticize the dude
because he's an authoritarian you know
he he's pro government mandate yeah
criticize what's wrong with his his
policies now i think it's fair to
criticize the hypocrisy of people saying
like the rich need to pay their fair
share and it's so unfair that some
people have so much and some people have
so little if you're going to argue like
that if you're going to argue that
employers should be paying their their
employees a higher wage well look if
like here's my thing right if you're if
you're saying
inequality is a moral outrage and you
have a net worth of 10 million dollars
well you can
do something right now in the world for
inequality by sharing a whole bunch of
your money with other people and so if
you don't i do think there's a level of
hypocrisy that can be criticized for
keeping all of this for yourself living
this very comfortable life and then
complaining that others don't share
their wealth let's break this down real
quick
as to what we're seeing
hassan [ __ ] works really really hard
and through his talent and his drive and
his passion he has become extremely
successful and made a lot of money
to him he's like i know i'm rich but the
real problem is that guy right below him
are the socialists saying you know look
we're not
wealthy we're middle class but that guy
and they're pointing at hassan so what
happens you have this scale where the
poor person with nothing is pointing to
the middle class saying these people
don't understand what they have the
middle class people are pointing at
hassan saying oh he's exploiting he
doesn't understand what he has then
people like ethan klein and his son are
pointing at bezos being like they're the
real problem the point is no matter
where you are at they're always pointing
at someone who's wealthier than they are
saying they're the problem and someone
in sub-saharan africa is like you're all
the problem
i have nothing it's it's the folly of
the anti-capitalistic mentality yeah you
know well that's right and i think to
the point michael was making before that
there is something that and one of the
worst parts i think about the the last
20 years particularly but really i guess
you could say since jekyll island but is
that
we
um
we have this crony corrupt system that
we call capitalism
and so of course people reject this
because they do know on some level that
this is unfair and it is unfair because
the whole system is completely rigged by
the powerful and of course that's true
but it's rigged through primarily
government policies bought and paid for
politicians regulatory capture a whole
series like an entire system that rigs
the game and what michael i think was
saying is that there is a difference
somebody who is just successful in the
market who has nothing to do with
government connections they are whether
you like the product that they're
selling or not the people buying it do
that's why they're buying it they have
made their wealth because they provide a
product that people want more than their
money and so they're willing to
voluntarily give their money up for that
product the people who make their money
because they have some type of
government connection some type of
regulatory capture some type of bought
off politician they make their money
because people are forced to pay them
for their product and that is unfair and
in the same sense that we bomb iraq and
call it operation iraqi freedom well i
wonder why no iraqi is going to want to
buy freedom anymore after that right the
left has gotten away with calling
corporatism or economic fascism
capitalism for far too long and if they
just dropped that they would find out
that we're against it too
there's a great example uh
candace owens tweeted
blackrock is buying up houses and
they're getting money from the
government this is communism and then on
reddit a bunch of progressives posted
that and saying literally capitalism and
i'm like yo you're both wrong
the point pointing at the communism
being like the government giving private
institutions free money to manipulate
control the system is not communism and
it's not capitalism it's fascism and you
can see where they each have enough of a
rationalization to sell it amongst their
base right because so so if you just
looked at the american system today it's
like okay well sean hannity can sell to
his base that this is socialism because
look how big the government is and look
at the deficit and look at all of this
right and look at the government and
involvement right so he can sell this is
socialism and then of course um you know
whoever msnbc equivalent of that you
know rachel maddow can sell it as this
is capitalism because look at the
corporate profits and look at it all
right so they they each have enough but
what we really l objectively if you look
at the whole picture here this is not a
battle between the idea that there's a
battle between big government and big
business at this time like okay like we
our government is what are they gonna
spend seven trillion dollars this year
they're the biggest government that's
ever existed in human history and look
at the size of big corporations they're
bigger than ever okay so clearly big
business loves big government and big
government loves big business this is
one conglomerate at this point and what
do you call that because there is a term
for it and it's not socialism or
capitalism that's fascism dave
economically thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you